šta je ovde šta, znači dobro ok, unosim ko artikali tipa iz dve boje, unosim boju 1, boje 2 i sa čom boje, to mi jasno
da
a šta je onda po vezi posled, a šta je napravio novi draft SSKU
pa to su dve opcije koje sam ubacio, ali ajde moga jer rati me pretkodno kako je bilo, nije mi problem, ako ti je lakše bilo
A ne, znam kako sam predskudno radio, nego ako je ovo bolje...
Jer ako recimo postojići artike, ne znam, ti si ubacio danas lupan crnu džezvu i za 3 dana bacaš belu džezvu.
Dobro.
I tu ubacaciješ recimo postojići artike, ali te nove džezove i toči porodicu, kako je reš?
Pa konta možda će ti tako biti lakše da...
ovde kad unosim tu drugu džezvu, onda samo poveži postojeći artikalu, unesem onu prvu džezvu i on će automatski da poveži
a šta je ovo napravi novi draft SKU?
pa sistem napravi neaktivan artikal koji kasnije dokuniš
aha
ja ratit ću, nije problem, ratit ću ono staro
mislim kako god očeš, me nije ono sve jedno
Čekaj da pitam, Jovana, ćeš da vrati Luka na ono staro ili da ostaje ovako sa im bojima?
Ne znaš da ste slušava.
OČeš na staro onda?
Može na staro.
Vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde, vajde